hallo deutsch schule punkt ch hören und
nachsprechen lektion 53
hört zu und spricht nach
was ist das
was ist das das ist ein wörterbuch das
ist ein wörterbuch
[Musik]
wer ist das wer ist das das ist mein
vater das ist mein vater was möchte er
trinken was möchte er trinken
er möchte einen tee trinken
was wünscht sich deine tochter zum
geburtstag
sie wünscht sich eine
sie wünscht sich eine katze gefällt dir
die
es liegt
gefällt dir dieses lied
ja ich finde es sehr schön
wie oft gehst du ins fitnesscenter
nie aber ich gehe zweimal pro woche
joggen
weißt du wo mein handy ist weißt du wo
mein handy ist ja es liegt auf dem
küchentisch
ja es liegt auf dem küchentisch
ja es ist in der schublade
nein ich habe keine ahnung wo dein handy
ist
trinkst du gern
ja ich liebe
ja ich liebe wein
nein ich trinke keinen alkohol
nein ich trinke lieber bier
entschuldigung ich habe dich nicht
verstanden
ich habe dich gefragt ob du gern wein
trinkt
ich habe dich gefragt
topcu gern wein trinkt
ich habe dich gefragt wo mein handy ist
ich habe dich gefragt
mein handy ist
wie oft du ins fitnesscenter gest
ich habe dich gefragt wie oft du ins
fitnesscenter gest
ich habe dich
ob dir dieses lied gefällt
ich habe dich gefragt ob dieses lied
gefällt
weißt du wann der nächste bus fährt
weißt du was
der nächste bus fährt
können sie mir sagen welches tram zum
schlussplatz fährt
können sie mir sagen
welches tram zum schlussplatz fährt
wissen sie vielleicht wo man in zürich
mexikanisch essen kann
wissen sie vielleicht wo man ihn zürich
ich habe keine ahnung warum der zug
nicht kommt
kannst du mir sagt
wie spät es ist kannst du mir sagen wie
spät es ist
der report
sie wissen ob es auf dem mars wasser
gibt
der report
wissen ob es auf dem mars wasser gibt
ich habe mich erkundigt ob man hier
passieren darf ich habe mich erkundigt
ob man hier passieren darf
er hat mir geantwortet dass er nicht zur
party kommt
er hat mir genannt
hat dass er nicht zur party kommt
entschuldigung darf ich sie etwas fragen
darf ich sie etwas fragen ja klar
können sie mir sagen wie ich zum
flughafen kommen können sie mir sagen
wie ich zum flughafen kommen ja
nehmen sie das tram nummer ziehen
ja nehmen sie das tor nummer 10
1 mir gefallen deine ohrringe danke ich
habe sie gestern gekauft
die hose ist mir zu eng
dann kaufte sie eine nummer größer
3 warum tragen sie kein hemd weil meine
waschmaschine kaputt ist
vier du gefällst mir in diesem anzug
danke dir passt mir ja auch sehr gut
5 die schwarzen schuhe sind toll
nein schwarz finde ich langweilig
bist du schon fertig nein ich muss mich
noch umziehen
gefällt dir mein neuer rock
ja du siehst hübscht arien aus
acht ich trage gern gelbe bluse ich
nicht mir steht gelb nicht
9 was trägst du an der party ich weiß
noch nicht vielleicht ein kleid
[Musik]